la femme de mon âge c'est à cannes que
monia chokri a été révélée au monde il
ya neuf ans en tant que comédienne cette
fois ci le festival salue ses talents de
réalisatrice
son premier long métrage la femme de mon
frère présenté en ouverture de la
section un certain regard reçoit le prix
coup de coeur du jury
coup de coeur ça me touche énormément
parce que je sais que c'est que vous
m'aimez vraiment est quelque chose qui
est un pays qu'elle partage avec le
réalisateur britannique michael angelo
calvino la comédienne réalisatrice était
bien entouré son ami xavier dolan et
l'équipe de son film était venu dans la
salle pour assister à la remise du prix
et la soutenir
une récompense dont la comédienne anne
élisabeth bossé tire une grande fierté
elle aussi puisqu'elle joue le
personnage principal dans le film serait
caché sur moi pourquoi pas ça dans le
monde c'est plaisant
si ce prix n'est pas le plus prestigieux
de la section un certain regard
il touche quand même beaucoup la
cinéaste s'est passé quelque chose nous
attendrions la femme de mon frère
raconte avec humour la relation
fusionnelle de sofia avec son frère
karim une relation bousculer lorsque
celui ci tombe amoureux de sa
gynécologue pour la productrice du film
nancy grenth ce prix tombe à pic
puisqu'il doit sortir en salles le 7
juin prochain au québec et en france
trois semaines plus tard
je pense que c'est le genre de cinéma
que j'ai envie de faire c'est toucher
les gens au plus profond d'eux mêmes
c'est demain pour doit connaître le
palmarès des films en compétition
officielle
et cette année difficile d'en prédire le
résultat attente il ya deux favoris le
nom de xavier dolan ne circule pas
beaucoup mais personne non plus n'avait
vu venir son grand prix du jury il ya
trois ans avec juste la fin du monde
ici jean françois bélanger radio canada